[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 101 of
the weekly Google Plus on podcast I am
Francis campoy and I'm here we make
colleague Michael dad hey Mark how are
doing I am good I am hanging out in my
parents house in Melbourne Australia so
it's really nice being nice in my home
very good very good
and I am here hanging out in my home
here in San Francisco
excellent yeah and very excited about a
really cool episode we've talked about
IOT core a couple times but we had not
done an episode yet so we got two people
from one from the IOT core team himself
itself an engineer Chakraborty but also
we got Gabe wise which is a developer
advocate in our team for cloud the word
specifically with a IOT in IOT core so
really really excited about that yeah
and then after that we'll have our
question of the week it's all about
France asked he wrote a really
interesting book yes and so we're gonna
talk about it it is about me
as each other but before that we have
our cool things of the week and there's
there's three of them the first one I am
going to say it because it is really
really exciting
we finally got go on the date on App
Engine standard environment which is
awesome and it is now generally
available it had been beta for a little
bit and now it is already the default
which is awesome if you've never used it
do not worry because it's as always
backwards compatible so if you reload
something with go on that five if we
will still work with go on delayed but
there's new things in go on the date
such as well context wasn't going not
six but go on that seven but there's
many many many new things that happen
since then but might make you happy and
happier gopher so check it out also
everything is faster as usual Rico yeah
always faster the second yeah cool thing
of the week is basically all about us
because we are the most important as I
should get it should be
we wrote a blog post celebrating the
fact that we hit a hundred episodes you
may have noticed we interviewed Cerf we
may have got a little excited about it
and maybe my voice went three octaves so
we wrote a blog post about it and in
that blog post we basically also list
the 10 most popular episodes that have
been downloaded from the podcast and
there's some good ones in there some of
my favorites
container engine we've can call burg
kubernetes 1.7 with Tim Hocking office
of CTO and Victor yeah class planner
with 52 ask the lab that wasn't that was
amazing yeah so they're all good so if
you're maybe not as familiar with our
stuff and you're just getting started
with a podcast you might want to go back
and have a look and the last cool theme
of the week is something that is really
really cool especially for those that do
not know Google+ from that well and they
get confused in between what is Club
beta lab and their prep and their studio
and all of these things there's a list
done by our dear manager Greg Wilson he
wrote a really cool cheat sheet I want
to come out because you have basically
for every single product a description
in four words or less and I agree with
most of them some of them are kind of
cheating but because what he does is
just he uses the words that the product
stands for it's like I mean if you say
IOT and you describe it as internet of
things I call that not this private much
but you know all of that it's actually
really good
no it is it is really good so for
example like cloud I am its resource
access control virtual private cloud is
like Software Defined Networking he
cheats a bit with hyphens so like cloud
functions is event and service
applications but no it totally is good
and it's also really nice in that not
only does it do for work descriptions it
also shows the free tiers for each of
the products as well so if you're like
what is this thing and also what can I
get for free it has a column there that
shows those for all the products that
have free tiers which is also really
nice I think it'd be an awesome thing to
give to people at conferences or even to
print it as something that you can have
in your office if you're using Google
clappa from a lot
help you in conversation with coworkers
yeah I think it's gonna help me actually
I'm gonna read through it there's
actually a very high brass image that
you can definitely print into something
quite big it can be a something to have
put on the wall layer of course oh my
god yes I kinda wanna do that yeah
excellent all right well why don't we go
talk to Gabe and ingénue and chat all
about cloud IOT core I am very excited
today to welcome two more people to a
podcast to talk about IOT core and
nonetheless we got internals to report a
product manager for IOT core hello
internal how are you doing hi Francisco
I'm doing fine thanks for having me here
today thank you for joining us and we
also have Gabe wise and he's a developer
advocate fellow developer advocate at
Google apart from working also for IOT
core and IOT stuffs how are you doing
I'm doing well how about you doing great
very excited we're gonna be talking
about IOT core we've mentioned it a
couple times here in the podcast but
like mostly as a cool thing of the week
and really quick without getting too
much into detail so today we're gonna
have the opportunity to talk a lot about
it but before that whether we start a
little bit by telling us who you are and
what you do here at Google we can start
with you engineer great so I'm internal
Chakraborty and I'm the product manager
for Google cloud decor and my job really
is to set the overall strategy and the
vision for the product work with
customers closely understand what the
needs are and then work with engineering
so that we can build the right product
which will add value to our customers so
my job really is to work with customers
engineering devrel marketing and other
cross-functional team so we're building
the right product for the customers cool
what about your game so I'm a developer
advocate for Google cloud platform kind
of focusing on not just IOT core but the
IOT platform so I'm really serving the
developers that are using the devices in
the world the connected devices to do
bigger better things so
IOT core specifically is the entryway
into the rest of GCP so I'm here to make
sure that the product that internal is
building with the cross teams really
does land with developers and make sure
that it's successful with them and that
they can use it to do their things
well cool all right so internal you're
the PM so I'm gonna ask you the hard
question
so 30,000 review like what is IOT core
from like a really basic standpoint sure
so if you if you think if you look at
Google cloud platform we have what we
believe is a state-of-the-art
well-received data analytics and machine
learning services today available for
our enterprise customers our developers
and our partners as well and what cloud
IT code does is it really makes it easy
to on board your IOT devices you know
things that are in your factory in your
oil and rake oil and gas rigs or other
Enterprise setting to easily on boards
devices to Google cloud so that you can
start pushing data from your devices to
Google cloud and start benefiting from
our data analytics and machine learning
services so that's essentially what
cloud article does it is a fully managed
service to securely connect and manage
your iot devices on Google cloud
platform cool so when you say to
securely connect what I'm expecting is
like there's some secure way to even
like start the communication how do you
make sure that those devices are the
devices you expect do you need to
install certificate in them what do you
mean by securely communicate yeah so we
deeply care about security of our of the
devices as well as the data that is
being transmitted from the device to
cloud so first as you as you mentioned
Francis Gates it's really about secure
can a secure connection of the device to
the cloud so IOT core supports
asymmetric key based authentication in
each individual device so what that
means is you will have a private key
which you will store securely which will
store in the device and then you would
register a public key from the device
based on the power private key on to
plot article so when the device makes a
connection to Clara de coal we can we
can verify based on the signature of the
device that it sends with the public key
to make sure that that device is really
what it's what it says it is and then we
we use in a standard jot token for
authentication between the device and
and
Nicole so the device will use the
private key to sign a jar token and then
it'll send a jar token to IOT core and
then then we use that your token to then
verify the signature with a public key
that is me registered so that's in one
aspect where we authenticate each device
at an individual level and second is
even for for connection
we support TLS 1.2 and above so we
expect that each device will use TLS 1.2
to make the initial connection to Google
Cloud rata Cordova TCP anything outside
if it's not TLS we reject the connection
that's first step and then you know
further as the data gets transmitted to
cloud article whether it's addressed in
the cloud or whether it's in transit the
data is always an encrypted form so we
ensure that with that that's the way we
ensure security at the device level
during connection as well as at the data
level as well and also for the the TLS
connection on the other end the device
will also need to have a root
certificate on it to verify on the other
side that the device knows is actually
talking to Google so you can either use
a Google provided root cert or when you
create your bucket in GCP for your
devices we call it the registry when you
create your registry you can specify a
third-party root certificate if you want
to use something else so that's the
other on the device side to make sure it
knows is talking to Google cool I have a
bunch of questions but the first one is
you said JA talking many times is that
BJ WT yes it is JW taste especially
Jason well okay cool all right so you
covered the security side of it what's
the communication part of it like what
does that actually mean
they just sending faxes to each other or
something or like what's the deal smoke
signal it's all smoke signal is part of
clarity cool we we realize that MPT is a
protocol which is pretty standard in the
industry and and so we started with a
native support for MQTT on on chirality
core so now with with mqtt devices can
publish telemetry even other information
on mqtt topic to IOT core and ID code
then aggregates all the data across all
the devices and
pushes it downstream too pops up topic
from where you can consume and then send
it downstream to other services such as
bigquery or BigTable and as such so
really the transmission between device
and and and communication between device
and article will depend on the protocols
if you use MQTT then you can publish
your telemetry on a certain topic and
then we take it from there if you're
using HTTP we also have support for HTTP
as you know if you use HTTP then you
would do a request response protocol to
send your data and telemetry to clarity
core and mqtt is that a bi-directional
protocol or is it just sending data from
the device down to cloud because I'm
glad you brought it up yes mqt is a
bi-directional protocol it is based on
TCP and the way it works is you know
your devices will publish certain data
to a particular topic and and cloud can
also publish data to a certain topic for
the device to subscribe to and get the
data so it is bi-directional and IT core
supports bi-directional data between the
device and the cloud over mqtt now that
we understand a little bit what these
product does and like the security part
of it
I am curious about what what is the
audience of this product meaning if if
I'm building I don't know like smart
light bulbs is this for me or if it's
I'm building like something like a home
hack where I have something like I have
just one little device I'm actually
trying to work on this by the way
something that like allows me to open
the garage door from my phone what is
this for yeah so you know cloud article
is really built for scale right so if
you if you think about an enterprise
company or a smart parking company they
have thousands and hundreds of thousands
of devices installed in different
parking lots and sub and on the curbside
and all of these devices and sensors are
sending data pretty frequently so
they've been able to connect all these
devices to quadratic or and and and
ingest the data at scale so I requite is
really designed for two to connect
massive amount of devices in just a
massive scale of data without
customer or the partner even the
developer needing to worry about the
infrastructure and provisioning you just
connect your devices with a connecting
one of millions of devices or even
billions we will scale internally we
will ingest data at scale without an
issue so that's what it's really
designed and built for now having said
that we understand that in a lot of
developers enterprise and even sort of
you know the commercial developers they
wanted to get their hands dirty they
want to build some quick prototype
before they can do before they deploy at
scale so we we made it easy and simple
enough for even the developers wants to
jumpstart their joining our journey on
IOT to be able to quickly build some
prototype using IOT core so we have we
do have a rich set of API s at the same
time we have a pretty simple user
interface for any developer or even an
operator for that matter to quickly
build some quick prototype to test out
the product and then before the scale so
really to going back to your question it
is designed for scale at the same time
we expect that we expect a wide spectrum
of customers and developers to use it
developers who are building it for
massive scale and for enterprise great
product at the same time developers who
are want to get their hands dirty they
want to build some quick prototype
before they graduate to the next level
whether it deploy a full scale devices
nice cool so Gabe I'm gonna direct the
stoops I know you've been building stuff
we don't ignore what does the
development experience look like I'm
pretty new to Google I just started in
May so one of the hardest ramp ups I've
had is learning all of the different
pieces of GCP learning all the API is
how to build stuff IOT core is by far
the easiest I've worked with so far
hands down
it's a managed service so you don't have
to stand that thing up you don't have to
start at UC you don't have to do
anything it's an endpoint so what that
means is I'm free to sit on my device
and I implement the three pieces that
need to worry about I need to worry
about the jaw authentication I need to
worry about initializing the
communication piece and then I need my
sensor data and my telemetry whatever
that ends up being and that's it I don't
have to download any SDKs from Google
Cloud I don't have to implement any
funky cloud stuff I can just put this
message together in MQTT publish it and
Google handles the rest of it and I and
with data in my cloud pub/sub topic so
from a development standpoint I have to
pick my library of choice I've worked
with Python OGS there's some C libraries
that work with just bare metal and it's
I just did this last week when I was at
the conference in Barcelona it's it was
a 10-minute theater talk where it was
bare device nothing on it and at the end
of ten minutes you have your messages in
in cloud they can do stuff with so it's
super easy and you didn't have to
install anything specific for IOT core I
mean you're just putting in some sort of
m QT client on the device that's very
standard that you don't have to worry
about oh yes so there's standards that's
the the three languages I mentioned so
they're just standard libraries for each
from paho MQTT is the kind of de-facto
MQTT library for across all of them shot
there's a PI JWT for python it's one
that I was using so those are the only
things you need to install on the device
and I suppose then also that means then
that you're not tied to a particular
like hardware provider or a particular
set of IOT device you can basically run
this on anything and pretty much
anything that can talk to the internet
so we've done everything from like the
lowest level the microcontrollers the
esp8266 are these little nice Wi-Fi
controllers that are like super slim
don't do anything other than Wi-Fi and
we've got it to work on those through
art we know PI and then on some of those
like industrial we've worked with a
couple of partners and their devices to
get those talking to core also nice so
I'm curious about the developing
experience you saying that you have a
basically a pub sub Q and that you're
receiving all the messages from there
which seems relatively easy I'm
imagining that when you receive that in
the payload there's some identification
of what is the origin like what is the
device exactly that is sending in the
data you don't necessarily unless you
put it in there you have okay you have a
record of the device as it's registered
in the system and there's some ID in
there but there wouldn't be any way to
like tie it pub/sub message back to your
device necessarily unless you added it
to the payload which is best practice we
recommend of course that you do that but
the bridge in IOT core is it's just it's
a pass-through so as the messages coming
to RIT core it bundles it up with some
metadata internal correctly from wrong
but I don't think it actually identifies
the device we we do have so pops up has
this notion of message
attributes I think as you guys know so
as part of message attributes we do put
the device ID as part of the message
attributes so when when you when you're
consuming the data from as a subscriber
from pops up every message you get you
can read the message attributes and you
can use that to know that this
particular messages been sent by the
thermostat in your living room versus
the thermostat in your bedroom for
example so the message pops a massive
battery which is where we where we add
the device ID nice so so once you have
that ID how do you reply to it
like what if you want to send a message
to a specific device so so there's two
things so one is for every time a device
publishes a message you know telemetry
could be a temperature measurement or
could be a pressure measurement -
priority call if I take or the MPD
bridge if it's able to publish that my
successfully pops up it will send an ACK
back to the device so the device that we
know that the message that it had sent
the measurement that data that it has
sent to IIT Corps has been received and
acknowledged that's one with
communication then the next is you may
want to as a developer you may want to
send some message back to the device
right or some communication or so
control command back to the device or
some configuration update back to the
device so we have part of IIT code
there's there api's which will allow you
to directly send a message to a specific
device ID so you can say I want to
change the temperature setting of the
thermostat in the living room you can
specify the device ID of the thermostat
and send a specific configuration change
to the device and the good thing about
IOT core is you know you know with IOT
the connection the connectivity is sort
of intermittent sometimes most of the
time it's there but sometimes because of
bandwidth constraint or because of the
location of whatnot there it's not
always continuously connected so IT core
makes sure that when you send the latest
configuration as when's the device if
the device is not connected where the
device comes back up and connects it
will send the latest configuration to
the device so from an application
perspective you know you you can you
build your application on and and you're
not worried about the upstream
connection and the data flow between the
new cloud and device IIT code takes care
of it
nice so service is the cool new buzzword
so it's either gonna be service or I'm
out like one or other I'm looking at
diagrams here on the clarity core
website and I see that there's a way to
hook in cloud functions or ease cloud
functions just really useful here
where's the where does that fit in what
functions is just super useful because
we have cloud functions you have the
hook for pub/sub message getting
subscribed so since i FD cor can extract
into pub/sub so everything you published
IOT core goes into pub sup your cloud
functions now can hook into that and do
stuff based on whatever you want it to
so you can route things too you can use
cloud functions throughout the data from
pub sub to anywhere you want stored in a
database send it along to you know a big
query or machine learning all the the
stuff that might be overkill for some of
the other systems GCP club functions
just a super nice lightweight way to do
some of that stuff yeah in fact if you
think about a use case a simple use case
where you know the you reading the
temperature setting from your thermostat
or then you're consuming it to pops up
you can have a cloud function which
reads the temperature setting and when
it goes above eighty degrees it can send
a message back to to the same thermostat
to say you turn off the air condition
right so there's a cloud function in
conjunction with like Gabe mentioned
with pub sub topic can really be used to
build very simple business logic with
articles so I think that's that's one
area where we do see developers kind of
trying out and building simple rules and
business projects and I just thought
about if this then that that's basically
what you're saying like you're able to
build a system that is basically just
events and cloud functions as the move
and stay completely serverless in that
in that fashion so you don't have to
like have any of these functions living
somewhere they just live in the cloud
that's cool since you were mentioning
use cases is there any other use case
that you've seen lately that was really
like exciting or or something that you
didn't expect when you were designing
this product when we designed the
product we always have sort of
commercial and enterprise segments in
mind and within even within this segment
there's been this I was I was personally
PMA's by some of the applications and
use case which customers and partners
have been using for so
one example is around ride-sharing and
you know this is something which is
picking up a lot in UK and Asia so the
notion of bike sharing Indian cities and
we're saying couple of our partners and
customers using it so that you know the
bikes are connected to quadratic or and
they have they have a mobile app so the
user as it goes gets closer to their to
the bike they've they've sort of has
been assigned to you
it automatically unlocks and so you can
start take the bike and start using it
so that is a pretty interesting
application which which we're seeing and
we're using the kinetochore I talked
about smart parking that's another area
where we we have a reference customer
who's been who's been using this for
notified the drivers about the specific
the particular parking lot that is open
and available the real-time but also as
they collect data they're also using it
to provide sort of more you know traffic
information to the city to for example
Auckland Transport in Sin City
so we're saying you know use case from
sort of ride-sharing to providing some
real-time information and then as they
collect this data that we also seen use
cases where the user data to provide
more advanced analytics around traffic
management or even in some cases
predictive maintenance is another area
where we're seeing a lot of these use
cases in manufacturing particularly yeah
this reminds me a lot of this interview
that we're preparing for next week we
smart parking where we they talk about
how they're using all of these
technologies and on Google cloud with
cloud functions obviously to basically
make parking smarter it's very exciting
yeah Gabe have you seen anything else
that's particularly interesting there's
a lot of stuff I was talking to one of
the partners last week about using IOT
telemetry data off of drones to map
really hard to reach places and then
using the GPS and altitude data off of
the devices to help create maps nice was
really cool so plans for the future
he's probably you know the creative
answers always you know we can speak
about roadmaps but I have to ask the
typical question we don't speak about
roadmaps but what about your roadmap
yeah well
there is there any new things on the
horizon that you can share with the
audience about what they can expect from
RIT core
so again you know we don't speak to our
roadmap but there there is one thing I
can guarantee is you know we see the
value in IIT core and how customers and
partners and developers are can use this
to to build really compelling
application on smart cities and in oil
and gas and manufacturing so the couple
of teeth let me instead of had a
high-level talk about you know three
things which we are we looking into one
is we we do want to do want to keep make
it really simple for both developers and
our partners to build application on
Google platforms specifically on IOT so
that's that's still that's still our
basic principle and we want to continue
doing that so so you would see a lot of
features around you know how do can you
quickly jump start your journey with IOT
you know on the UI side on the API side
we started with managed service we
started with MQTT but we want to make it
even more simpler so your overall
onboarding experience can become really
frictionless for you to get started with
any device and any sort of hardware you
want to do so that's one you know one
area where we want to continue investing
we will invest more and then you see
some feature releases in in in
subsequent couple of months you know the
second area really is our partner
partner ecosystem is is it is pretty
strong we have a we have a good number
of hardware partners around you know we
think about Intel NXP microchip Marvel's
here Wireless all these priority device
and hardware partners have agreed and
they build simple libraries that you can
once you buy these devices as a
developer from these partners you can
easily and seamlessly connect to cloud
or attic or and start building
applications so we're going to continue
to build out a partner ecosystem both on
device set as well as on the application
side so the four developer it hits
makers it makes it even simpler for them
to build an end-to-end application third
area is you know we we do have as I
mentioned we do have a pretty rich set
of services for data analytics time
series analysis machine learning
and what we want to do is make it even
more simpler and sort of more integrated
to to our overall Google IT core and the
severity platform so that the developers
can sue and I can really start using it
without needing to write hundreds of
lines of code so I think those are the
three areas where you would see us sort
of investing more in in in near future
awesome okay about direct this to you if
people want to learn more about IOT core
learn how to get set up and how to get
going where should they go
cloud google.com slash IOT - core that's
it that's it cool yep so there's a beta
page you can view all the docs from
there there's a bunch of kind of
QuickStart guides and examples already
up and a couple different languages so
everything should be there to get you up
and on your feet really quick and for
those people that are lazy like me and
like videos the talk that you gave you
in Barcelona recently was that recorded
is there any video that we might want to
check out not yet but I'm planning on
recording something awesome alright cool
well if anything comes up in the
meantime we'll put in the show notes
before we wrap up today we like to give
everyone the last chance is there
anything that you want to mention or
plug or any events coming up or anything
like that that you want to make sure
that our listeners know about in case we
have missed it on this episode so far I
would I would I would just say that you
know we're very excited with this beta
release for clarity core we're seeing a
tremendous amount of you know interest
in and traction and we're really excited
and really happy with that we've
released this product and so developers
and partners can really build compelling
application you know our goal really
next step is to get this to GA so that
you know developers and customers can
really think about production deployment
man had get the peace of mind with SLA
as well so we're excited and anything in
terms of the developer content
conference or let gate speak to it yeah
from our perspective like like a journal
said making sure that we make it to GA
is our priority right now so I know
early in 2018 we've got a couple of
conferences coming up where we're gonna
be really kind of diving deep getting
people on board with it and exploring
more but nothing specific in the super
near future
right well looking forward to that and
thank you so much both internal engage
we're taking the time today to talk
about IOT thank you yep thanks for
having us
thanks again to both internal and Gabe
for telling us a little bit more about
what IOT core is and what people can
build on top of it yeah it's a really
cool platform and if you're interested
at all
the next episode that is coming up we
are talking to a customer who is using
it in production and they have a really
really really cool use case that I think
is quite interesting yeah super
interesting interview so looking forward
to that
excellent all right well why don't we
get stuck into the question of the week
so I figure we normally talk about DCP
but in this instance France sq posted up
a really interesting blog post I rented
a lot I found it quite fascinating
you're leaving Google what about me what
am I gonna do without you what's going
on why why why why why yes I wrote that
little blog post that when a little bit
viral and I've got a lot of people
asking me whether I'm moving to
Microsoft or head-tail I'm not moving to
Microsoft I know moving to hello I'm
joining a tiny tiny startup that I will
be talking more about it later on but I
would be still doing a lot of go I will
be still going to all of the go
conferences so if people want to see me
there I will still be there so don't
worry I will still be do it justice funk
the only thing I will not be doing is
talking to you mark on these beautiful
beautiful podcast and it is not because
I really want to stop talking to you
which partly you know it's funny because
I am very excited new experience new
opportunities so I could not say no
that's totally fair enough um so who do
we have replacing you I am very excited
about this and I say all the time in
this podcast I am very excited but I am
sincerely excited about it because I so
I think it was episode 93 correct me if
I'm wrong episode 93 we had an episode
the difference between AI a machine
learning and basically all of these came
up without because we're having a lunch
conversation with Melanie work and as
I'm sure everybody noticed she's super
cool
yes oh yeah so we decided that since
she's so cool and so interesting and
also pretty good at doing podcasts that
maybe she'd be just replacing me so we
asked her and she said yes so yeah so
super excited and I'm super excited to
introduce Melanie work Melanie how are
you doing I'm good thank you I'm really
looking forward to taking over taking
all the things and destroying mark now
[Laughter]
exactly the same it's fine yeah that's
right it's one guest against mark the
guest changes the host changes but
that's okay that's fine I guess my firm
yep yeah that's fine Melanie if people
didn't manage to catch her episode 93
you should totally listen to it do you
have to tell the audience a little bit
about yourself yes I am basically senior
developer advocate at Google and work
and Google cloud platform working on AI
and machine learning and before that I
worked at change.org doing machine
learning in production as well as worked
at a start-up building out an
open-source neural net platform in Java
that was not tensorflow so those are my
kind of tracks to get down the path into
software engineering and data science
but yeah I'm looking forward to this
this will be fun mark you'll you'll
you'll have a little bit of a different
experience with me for sure but I think
we can factor topics to dive into I look
forward to Adam I've worked with Francis
for now two years it's fine
yeah we need change now in 100 101
episodes are Francis all the time so I
think it's time to change you maybe it
takes more than 24 hours or what to
listen to all that oh yes oh my god yeah
that's terrifying now that I think about
it I know right save a lot of time
Francisco you're gonna be missed and
hopefully we'll get a chance to get you
back and come visit and tell us about
all the things you know I be very happy
to
come back as a guest any time especially
you know I've heard the de San Francisco
office is still serving really good free
lunch so we can always organize it with
me
free lunch is very valuable especially
when you're working for a start-up yep
absolutely
Oh Francis thank you to you for home and
hundred and one episodes of us doing
this together it has been a delight and
a pleasure you are definitely going to
be missed
thank you so much it was indeed an
amazing experience
101 episodes and we've interviewed
people like I don't know Dean Sir John
Wilkes you know like basically all of my
big heroes of computer science have been
there we have not interviewed all of
them yet so it's hopefully up to you and
Melanie to convince them and go get
every single one of them notably I know
that melanie is into AI and stuff and
I'd love to have an episode and gonna
ask this as a departure present I want
as a gift and interview with a fairly
nice I'm a fan of Feifei leaves as well
so I like I like that you're making a
request on your way out the door is this
like yes yes my last wish is an episode
with a fairly no myself as a host but I
will definitely listen to it that's fair
that's totally fair but yeah but thank
you thank you Mark for really really
sometimes long times 101 episodes we've
around 30 to 45 minutes each that's a
long time of us speaking but still it
was awesome and you know looking forward
to the 100 next episodes and seeing what
you and Melanie are able to build
awesome well France asked for the last
time
thank you so much for joining me on this
episode this week thank you Mark and
Melanie for joining me in this episode
today and thank you all for listening
wonderful and we'll see you all next
week have a good one
[Music]